Found
and his life
seems
wasly
when he was
delivered by
was able
and
pro
considered
Muham
that is even more
to the people.
all a book that contains your honor and
nobility in it if you would only reason.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
begins that mention here in these
verses, these two verses. He said
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
10.
[Silence]
for
Shahid.
[Silence]
So he says indeed we have sent to you
all a grand a very
esteemed messenger
who is simultaneously a messenger and a
witness upon you All a witness
in what?
He is a witness
upon those of us who believe. He is a
witness for us on the day of judgment.
And he is a witness for those who
disbelieve.
A witness against us, against those who
disbelieve on the day of judgment.
And so one of the functions of the
messenger
of all the messengers
is that they act as a witness on the day
of judgment. And the book they are given
by Allah is a book that in it has
testimony for or against the people that
they were sent to.
And so
he mentions that he has sent to us all a
messenger as he has to Pharaoh. That
very arrogant man sent upon him a
messenger as a witness and as a
messenger. And what was the reception of
this messenger with Pharaoh?
foreign.
[Silence]
for
and this here is a very interesting
choice of words. He says,
"And so Pharaoh immediately disobeyed
the messenger." immediately.
He did not even hesitate in disobeying
the messenger.
Not because he didn't believe he was a
messenger.
He believed he was a messenger. If he
was not convinced that he was a
messenger, then
the argument isn't strong enough. No,
the argument was
irrefutable.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
the opening verses of surah kasus he
says that pharaoh and his followers
they rejected it outwardly but in their
heart of hearts they were certain of the
validity of Moses's messengership and
prophethood. They were positive of it.
And for this reason, in some instances,
Pharaoh doesn't deny that. Mam says to
Pharaoh,
he says, "You know, MS said to Pharaoh,
you know
that Allah,
the Lord of the heavens and the earth,
is the one who has sent these messages,
sent these verses, sent these miracles
with me." You know that. Pharaoh didn't
say, "No, I don't know that. I'm not
convinced." He was convinced. Just like
Abu Jah was convinced. They were all
convinced of this. The issue wasn't were
they convinced or not or did they
acknowledge it in their heart of hearts.
That doesn't make a person a believer.
What makes a person a believer is what?
Adherence.
Adherence. Imagine with me if someone
were to receive the message of Islam
and in their heart of hearts believe
truly
thatahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
they believe this truly in their heart
of hearts but they refuse to say it and
they refuse to adhere to it are they
Muslim does that make them a Muslim
absolutely not That's exactly the extent
of the belief of Pharaoh. The issue is
not just being being convinced
or having conviction. That's not enough.
There has to be adherence.
Remember when we mentioned the three
elements that make up a Muslim?
What is Islam?
say it as we as we mentioned
Islam is three components. They have to
come together in order for a person's
Islam to be valid. What what are the
three components? Number one, submission
to Allah with
the second.
The second is adherence
to Allah with obedience. Adherence to
his commands with obedience. Holistic
general obedience. Even if it's 1%,
there has to be some degree of obedience
there.
And the third component
and the third component disassociation
from
and its people. These three components
have to be simultaneous
in a person's heart and a person's
actions in a person's speech in order
for their Islam to be valid. Otherwise,
if any one of these three is missing,
the person's Islam is what is deficient
and unaccepted.
It hasn't even begun. And that is the
meaning
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah.
Abu jah he believed
in a linguistic sense. He had
conviction. He was convinced that
Muhammad was the messenger of Allah.
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam and he
admitted as much in many instances
Abu Talib believed Abuab believed in
this sense right
doesl believe that
[Arabic recitation]
no why is it because he didn't have
conviction
now he has conviction it is What
[Arabic recitation]
It is complete
disobedience.
Here Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he
doesn't mention that Pharaoh
disbelieved. In other places he mentions
that.
But he mentions here that he
assa meaning he disobeyed the messenger.
He disobeyed him. He didn't disobey him
here or there. He disobeyed him
fundamentally
just likel disobeyed Allah's command.
What?
Fundamentally
when he was commanded to what? Make
sujud to Adam. And with that
disobedience he what? Disbelieved.
Right.
And so there is no such thing as just
conviction in the heart that is just
there. And a person then has integral
dis disobedience. This only comes
from a disbeliever and this is one of
the types of disbelief. There are many
types of disbelief.
Right? This is one of them and one of
them is
complete
utter disobedience.
Pharaoh he completely disobeyed.
Allah says
that Pharaoh disobeyed the messenger.
Notice again
Tortench.
[Silence]
for.
And so this means that as soon as the
messenger came to him, he immediately
proceeded to disobey. And as he
immediately proceeded to disobey, he was
immediately taken by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Now what does that mean?
Immediately taken by Allah. How many
decades did MS spend in Egypt? A long
time. How long did it take for Abu Jah
to be taken by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala? 15 years. 15 years.
This here means nothing in in in
eternity. It is nothing. It's a blink of
an eye. It's it's not even a part of a
day. And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says,
[Silence]
wasn't
foram
[Silence]
and Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says, "And so
he disobeyed the messenger. And so we
took him with a very strenuous, very
harsh and very heavy and grave
punishment. And that punishment, Allah
will elaborate on it later. But at this
point the punishment is undefined.
This remember this is the first
introduction of Pharaoh's story in the
Quran to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. They may have heard of it from
here or there but the introduction was
just touched upon. It was a very
terrible punishment.
What was the punishment like? It'll come
later. we will some details of this
punishment will start to emerge and fill
in the blanks. And this is the most
the most eloquent of ways is that a
person creates curiosity in the listener
and then fills in the details
after the curiosity has been created in
the listener.
And this is the method that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala takes here. He
creates curiosity in the listener. What
kind of punishment was it? How was it?
What was it like? we see that it was
very quick. It was very swift. How swift
was it? Those details are filled in
slowly over a number of years.
Each time a new detail comes, it
satisfies a bit of that curiosity until
an entire picture is painted. Now,
No, he that was when his soul was being
taken out of his body.
[Arabic recitation]
never heard that before.
[Silence]
and he called on MS and so I've
never heard that before.
[Arabic recitation]
matter how many times you say it, I'm
still going to have the same answer.
[Arabic recitation]
tomorrow. Very good. Tomorrow the is at
7:30 in